every given ship
forbidden to leave the suez canal until
its owners pay up to a billion dollars
in compensation for the chaos it caused
business insider story
egyptian authorities said that they
wouldn't release the massive ship which
was stuck in the source canal for almost
a week until its owners agreed to pay up
to a billion dollars in compensation
lieutenant general osama rabi who led
the suez canal authority said egyptian
authorities would demand a billion
dollars to cover the cost of
freeing the vessel the figure would
cover the expense of the equipment and
machinery used to clear the way in
damage to the canal itself
by the dredging uh while also
compensating about 800 people who work
to release the 200 000 ton ship
it would also fund the cost from
blocking the canal which ended up
causing an epic traffic jam of more than
400 ships on either side of the channel
fair or unfair it's extremely unfair
um unfair to charge the billion like
they should just take the
hit themselves it just makes them seem
unsophisticated it's it's like a ransom
it's crazy one billion dollars how about
we're discussing this
some sort of settlement but meanwhile
the 25-man crew is held hostage
they haven't been allowed to leave that
ship even though they are members of a
union by the way shout out to amazon's
great success with their union vote
they can't get them off the boat but i
think it's just crazy it makes you think
i never want to go to egypt
my god is if this is the way they do
business or or or the suez canal how
unsophisticated this
this governance is of it i i'm shocked
by it it's sitting right there
just to come out and say a billion
dollars is irrational and crazy
well this was costing what 400 million
dollars an hour
as far as like how much it was costing
profits or
however i don't know how they calculated
that number commerce commerce
so yeah i i agree that i actually i'm
going to take the other side of this
thing i think a billion dollars is a
a hefty pay egypt if that was the global
economy that suffered from that
right yeah well egypt is the the the
country that it all went down they want
their money bro they just you know
so you're supporting egypt by the way
they haven't been able to build that
ship either
with my egyptian friends on this one by
the way shout out to our muslim friends
out there today is the first day of
ramadan
and you know from a jew to a muslim
sitting with a christian
sitting with uh i don't know i don't
know
i don't know i don't know where you are
he's a christian christian you know just
shout out to all our people out there
like can't we all just get along
just like our friend um ronnie i agree
i agree so okay so you're sticking to
the bill
i think the billion dollars is uh
fair because if you are being urgent
about
going out there and bringing all these
the dredging the people
i i just don't know how they go about
doing it how do you come up with the
math to figure out would it be the ship
owner to pay for that is it his fault
whose fault was it the wind
is that because the cause of it then
that's going to cause an investigation
because the ship owner is going to say
why am i going to pay for this i didn't
do it i didn't cause the win i didn't
call
everything that happened here this is
your fault so there's so much greater
you could have built out the dam more i
mean yeah damn hasn't been touched yeah
yeah that's pretty much
the argument yeah i agree so why why and
what does that money go to just do
damages or to build out but don't get me
wrong
they did take a hit though there is a
hit taken but i would want to know what
caused it
if it's man-made or if it's nature if
it's nature why don't you sue god
send the bill to him see what's going to
if he's going to pay for it or not he
might pay
the hard costs by the way are about 120
million for for the digging the dragging
the towing
the all that stuff is about 120 million
so to me a billion is exorbitant
i mean this is something how do you
settle this right away you don't hold a
ship hostage and say
pay a billion or you can't move on
there's 20 000
crates on there that they haven't been
able to unload that's affecting a lot of
people that paid for that
that it's supposed to be coming through
that's what insurance companies are for
those are the
that's the that's what's going to
eventually pay the toll on this anyway
so it seems like a number that kind of
made up like oh
a billion all right go with it there's
no math involved i think it's just pure
emotional you better not screw up the
next time you go through the suez canal
man they are not playing no
i know you're planning on going there in
a few weeks so just take it easy with
yeah
it's going to be it's going to be a fun
trip out there it's going to be a fun
trip out there
by the way he's kidding i don't want
people to think i'm going to sue us okay
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye